I'm Charlie Ashe night I'm gonna be
talking about new and image and audio
processing and the new capabilities we
are adding is basically aiming towards
having smaller more immigrated and more
effective abilities looking forward to
seeing you
hello everyone I'm Sean I've been doing
this for a couple years now what's new
in image and signal processing this year
we named it image and audio processing
because audio is still evolving a whole
lot there are a whole lot more talks
from the team in this conference and
they are all more in depth because they
have more time to talk about specific
contents just to show briefly what has
happened since last year in the domain
of image processing this is just a list
for 11:1 arithmetic some statistics more
computer vision photography microscopy
ILD stuff as Steven keeps talking about
it and file format support the
development continues into xi xi to the
list never gets sure there 11:3 and
these are just the things that we have a
rough prototype of it either in the
version that you have received or in the
nightly builds that we are playing with
so promising feature that is coming but
still probably a lot more than this is
going to be eventually into the xi
rebuild the audio features list is not
even sure there we have continued with
audio GUI development just to make it
more robust last year when we just
released version 11 all you agree was
you know not not so mature so we
continued developing on that added
capabilities for all your capturing more
analysis processing and things like that
and of course as well more file format
support 11 to again a fairly impressive
list of capabilities I would say the
most importantly the programmatic
playback which is going to take us to
the real-time processing of the audio
objects and then yet again they live in
three upcoming West's not not even sure
they're it's it's just great for me to
see that as all the areas in the Wolfram
language the language itself helped us
develop faster and faster and after ten
years of developing image processing the
pace is not slowing down audio same
thing and I'm hoping soon we're gonna be
talking about video not today
all right so impossible for me to cover
all of those but I thought I'll
emphasize on the main goals that we are
trying to follow down the road what do
we want to see well from language being
able to do in the domains of image and
audio processing I think very quickly on
this intro slide and then I'll go into
the details we would like to have easier
access to data whether it's import or
other kinds of image captain image audio
capture or data data access we want to
make that as easy as possible and as
immediate as possible so that you don't
have to worry about that we are making
the function smarter so that a user who
doesn't necessarily need to do you need
to know algorithms for image processing
or speech analysis or any of that is not
feeling comfortable approaching our
system for finishing or solving a task
that is dealing with algorithms for
image segmentation or edge preserving
smoothing or detecting formats from an
from an audio signal to come to a
conclusion about the speech signal but
just use the machine learning used in
neural networks and use that all their
strength and the language to make sure
our functions are higher level smarter
and more to the point for whatever test
that has to has to happen we're trying
to be more acquired looking into
different verticals Roger this morning
talked about computational photography
for instance we have been looking into
computer vision photography microscopy
specifically for the image processing
capabilities that we have we think those
are the relevant market but also trying
to plan and look into many other markets
I know you're coming from diverse set of
application areas and this is a great
opportunity for us to interact and know
what are the interesting features that
you look to have and look forward to
having the system let us you know give
us feedback let us know what what are
your interests and what are the missing
features so that we can keep building on
them and then now that we can bring all
your signals and I think the two big
verticals or application areas dealing
with all your signals is going to be
speech and music for us that at least
the first ones that we're going to be
looking into I think down the road we
may be looking into machinery sounds and
things like that but again give us
feedback on what are the what are the
things that we should be looking for
what are the big markets out there that
are looking for tools that will solve
their problems we are in trying to be as
integrated as possible with the rest of
the system just because we see that our
sub system is much stronger much
powerful and much use much more useful
if it is integrated with the rest of the
system so we're building the bridges to
make the connections we are making
consistent consistency update whenever
we see that well the design of this or
that feature that we have added is not
super consistent not easy to remember
we're trying to fix all of those and
obviously we are trying to be feature
completed as much as we can and then one
last thing we are trying to document
things as well as we can so that you can
train yourself on individual functions
that we are releasing based just on the
ref pages that are available on
documentation alright so let's get
started with actual updates so that's
happened for easier access to data
important is obviously the first go-to
for bringing data in give PNG tiff we
have had a major updates about them
especially with multi frame versions of
them Fitz's another is another one that
we are putting major improvements into
it astronomy applications strongly
depend on a good fits import/export and
then m4a which is the major file format
that is created by Apple products
basically is added for audio signals we
used to have current image before I
don't think anyone here hasn't seen a
demo from Karen image so this connects
to the webcam and gets an image from the
camera but now we have other things
other ways of bringing images in like
Karen Notebook image or current screen
image which in my case in fact it's
going to be fairly similar because I'm
doing a full screen thing web image
search Stephan showed that last night as
well is a very interesting quick way of
great getting access to images from the
web
so let's see if we can get this going
all right apart from the error message
we have some thumbnails of hippos geo
images give us access to satellite
images coming from different servers as
it was discussed and brought up earlier
and then other ways of Korea one other
way of creating going from all the
geometry computational geometry
capabilities that we have that create
meshes and mesh regions and so forth or
just the region specification this is
actually a raster image if I actually
unfortunately don't have the toolbar
that we typically get but the get image
information it's a 360 by 360 or
whatever dimensions you specify and so
forth the good thing is that we have a
3d version of this so unlike rasterize
that we have it only for 2d or even it
rasterizes 3d graphics and 3d regions
into 2d raster images now regional image
is a function experimental still that
connects that gets a region in and tries
to do you know typical algorithms
marching cubes and things like that to
construct an actual 3d volume of pixels
associated to the region that was
specified and then the last thing back
to the audio domain audio capture is
another function that we added we had
the system dialogue input sound or
record sound that got updated this I
think is a more modern way of and
actually a lot more robust way of
recording audio signals from your
microphone so we'll start recording
recording recording and then once you
stop and actual all your objects come
back ok so the functions are becoming
smarter and higher-level broad use of
neural network and machine learning
image identify had been in the system
for a while this gets one image and
identifies what is the content or what's
the main object seen in the image should
have downloaded the networks maybe I'll
start just running all the other ones as
well in image contents which has been in
the builds I think since version 11 one
is not yet documented but as soon as
again and networks
and we see the result this is trying to
look into the contents of the image and
give a data set of what are the
different objects it can find so unlike
image identify that is seeing only the
main object of the image image contents
drills in and tries to see different
objects that are available in in that
image want to see if I can go hard for
it to be faster a little bit on those
yes and then more things that are coming
net model you have seen already as well
demoed in the keynote last night we are
converting a whole lot of pre-trained
network into mathematical neural net
models that can be represented and then
used okay so this is the result from
image contents let me actually just
start getting this other network as well
while talking about that so image
contents gives us the bounding boxes the
concepts associated to those objects
detected in those bounding boxes
dimensions the right from boxes images
positions or the right from that and
then as well probability so it says how
confident we are in detecting that
object so all right so back to this
other net network a lot of actually a
lot of image processing and still
nothing for audio on the net model but
hopefully soon there will be something
this this one is doing some kind of a
depth estimation based on the image so
associating a relative depth to it to
each pixel in the image and then once
you have that this is just a visual that
says roughly how that depth estimation
algorithm works but as you see these are
more high-level things that you don't
have to really worry about how the
algorithm is doing all of that we're
trying to again put together functions
that are directly usable for for general
applications combined functionality to
build higher level functions is one
thing that we probably started on first
in removed background a lot of it is
already in the system things like sölden
and isolde and things like that are
already trying to combine a lot of
algorithms and 2:1 sum of image
processing functions do it as well
remove background in fact links to a lot
of segmentation function under the hood
to try to infer what algorithm would
work better for removing the background
and things like that so combining a
whole lot of different features together
so that you get one powerful function
one go-to function to solve your problem
and then other things like facial
feature that is as well upcoming
probably takes more because it requires
multiple networks but this one for
instance uses a neural network for age
estimation another one for emotion
estimation gender estimation one for
detecting landmarks on the face eyes
knowing nose and things like that and
then all of that combined you get in one
place all the necessary features for
doing any kind of face analysis in case
if you haven't been downstairs at our
booth yet there is a very cool demo for
doing different kinds of face analysis
downstairs with your your face captured
through the camera I guess we'll just
skip waiting for this particular network
it may take a little longer more on
target more in detail I think tomorrow
there is going to be this talk by Julian
McHale on face analysis and OCR again
more on target
neural networks for images and neural
networks for all you both twelve one on
Friday one on Thursday as well oops if
it doesn't work don't just give up on
that basically shows you how you can use
and leverage the neural networks
framework to build an image processing
or all your processing capability in
into the Wolfram language so we talked
about the fact that we're trying to be
more applied I already showed a few
demos for computer vision and then down
the road some other verticals that we're
going to talk about face analysis I
think it's going to fail again you saw
enough failing text analysis in fact
nothing much in the version of 11:3 that
you have apart from the update that we
had I think in version than one where we
can specify second third arguments of
Tech's recognize being the granularity
of the of the text that we would like to
detect the whole thing lines wards
characters and things like that and then
we can also ask for properties like
bounding box as well for strength or the
confidence in the detection of the
character and things like that and then
this is just basically the same example
with with words what is going to be very
major for OCR is the detection of the
text again we are working with neural
networks to be able to detect the
location of the text which is basically
the ultimate goal is to make the
recognition better but the detection is
obviously the first step to to do the
detection so all of that is going to be
coming as well well
these I think I've already done once and
again in the computer vision we are
doing we have already done things like
image identify image contents and fairly
easily highlight things on top of that
to see where it's where we are going but
also things like motion tracking where
we can do things like image
displacements of my series of images if
I do something like I'm sorry this plot
of that let's animate of that so you'll
see we have some rotating object in
there and for in order to understand
what's happening in the image we can do
displacements compute the curl of the
displacement in order to find the
rotation and some kind of a heat map of
where objects are more rotating as for
the domain of microscopy we spent some
time for them together putting together
some examples that are targeted to the
people working with microscopes in
different fields biology material
sciences and quite a few more actually a
lot more working with microscopes one
thing for dealing with microscopes was
basically bringing data in typically
microscope vendors worked with various
commercial specific file formats for
them and the Spiro format library is the
one
actually gives us access 250 file
formats pure talked about the talked
about this earlier today the recording
should be available and this was a Java
library with j-link we actually
connected to hit tweet the library is
available online on github open source
and then we have done a lot of analysis
and processing examples and this blog
post that got released earlier this
month we have connected to this slice
microscope doing different things like
brightness equalization color D mixing
viewing and manual measurements 3d focus
stacking and 3d reconstruction as well
actually in the booth we have downstairs
you can come and play with the
microscope and talk about more
applications that we have done and then
things with machine learning and neural
networks doing things like image
classification or detection of the last
example here I'll let you go through it
there was too much I decided I'll just
leave you with the lengths to go through
as I said for astronomy we have done a
good update on Fitz and then things like
brightness equalization that is also
applied to microscopy is applicable to
astronomy applications where you have
dark fields that you would like to use
in order to get a more uniform
background and then this is this is
basically the result of that photography
image effects and maybe I should as well
start evaluating everything here some of
these we have shown last year editions
from last year more effects an image
effect for things like sepia color tones
jitter but also a lot of framings that
often is going to be used for remember
blending images into each other and then
composing an image on top of itself and
things like that you know kind of just
oh this is not responding because
there's of some other things I mean
valuating maybe I'll just let it
I'll just said you play with that as I
don't have a whole lot more time but
imagery style that has been demoed a lot
today things like restyle with template
images like the four images of paintings
of four seasons but also you can use
image itself like the edge detect
version of the image to do restyling or
quantized version of the image to do
restyling and things like that and
talking about quantization one of the
additions as for incremental
improvements is to get more methods
faster methods better quality method
methods like color quantize was updated
with newer methods that are actually
performing much better than the for HDR
image creation for those doing
computational photography we had a
function called image exposure combined
that took differently exposed stack of
images combine it together to get a good
exposed image all over but we also added
a small modification to it so that the
user can get back you can get back to
HDR version of it just in case you have
an HD high high definition display to
display it on or in case you want to do
your own color tone mapping on that and
don't want to rely on our color tone
mapping that is baked into the function
as for speech synthesis I think a more
detailed version of what's coming and
nothing much baked into the system yet
is going to be in Carlos talk on Friday
what is in the builds and is new I'm not
connected to the internet I believe here
I'm sorry the sound
I don't quite know how to work that the
volume here that's okay probably we
don't have a lot of time to but all of
you know what speak used to do speak the
word the sentence hello welcome to the
to the talk speech synthesizes the
function that actually gives you the
audio waveform to to then process
analyze something might be wrong with
the yeah that's okay well we'll go
without it I don't think I don't think
it's gonna be and then well won't be
able to play this again but we have
access to different voices different
methods and things like that to do
speech recognition speech synthesis
speech recognition very very much on
their development we're trying to make
improvement into our neural network
framework in order to be able to handle
all you as well I'll just probably leave
this for us now as well but what it does
is basically we have used a very small
data set of speech and I'll try to at
least see if all your capture may work
alright so we have we have trained a
small network with 150 recordings of
different digits 0 to 9 3 speakers the
the data set was available online and
then this train network that is imported
is supposed to recognize that they did
digit that is in the audio signal okay
let's try this sorry okay that's the
audio signal that's the plot of it these
are the parameters we would like the
network to use well I wasn't saying it
close enough to whatever the Train yeah
and and I think this is as I said very
much on their development I really
didn't expect it to do do the right
thing some of the example I was playing
with actually work okay more integrated
read
okay raster image to mesh regions so we
have we would like to bridge make a
bridge between image images and regions
so here we have a binary image we call
image mesh and go from the raster image
domain to boundary mesh region we can do
different things now in that domain that
is not easily doable in the image domain
and then we get a 3d printed printable
region basically as well for 3d as I
said region the image mesh is also
available there so we get a 3d volume we
do some binarization and then we
converted to a region that then we can
do other modifications like
transformations or anything else that
might be easier faster or well-defined
better defined on that domain going from
regions to images the other way around
is also implemented in this experimental
function called called region image so
here we have this mesh we do some
smoothing and then convert it from a
raster image to a mesh and then here is
another example with a 3d region that we
rasterize into a 3d image and the good
thing about the function region image is
that it's not platform-specific like how
rasterize was so if you're doing
something that requires creating a mask
that you would like to be consistent
across platforms and so forth this is
basically they go to function the other
thing that was added was the function
image graphics the goal of image
graphics is to go from raster images to
graphics to scalable vector graphics I
think the holy grail of that would be to
convert scanned plots and things like
that from very old papers to actual
actual graphics that have proper tix and
proper plot lines and and all of that
detected and put together the current
version of it again experimental because
of some design uncertainties we had but
the current version basically only
detects 2d segments of an image to the
regions in the image that are of similar
color and try to form
a form a scalable vector graphics so if
I basically scale the input image here
you see that at some resolution it
starts to pixelate because it is a
finite dimension raster image and this
is the image graphics version that is
actually scalable and then this example
I'll just leave it to you to play with
it we're starting from a simple you know
we are starting from an actual image and
trying to create an ionized vector
graphics icon from it
one other addition for a better
integration is wavelet support for audio
something we didn't find time to do it
for the release of audio in version 11
so we added that what what is happening
here unfortunately I can again play the
audio objects we will return we work so
this is the noisy signal and after going
through wavelet transform a threshold
some of the noise is gone so I think
it's going to be valuable just just to
have all of it available and so forth
arithmetics and statistics operations on
images has been added very recently so
just like we could do athletics on time
series for a while and then on audio in
version 11 as it got released I can get
an image do some color quantizations do
some dilation and things like that
multiply one image by 2 and then
subtracted from each other to get any
effect that you want and this can be as
sophisticated as you want
also statistical operations just
directly are available things like min
max median it seems trivial but it
actually takes a whole lot of the
development effort to get those working
and get them working consistency
consistently one thing that we changed
for audio in fact for statistical
operations is that if we do have a
multi-dimensional audio object and if
regardless of all your image what we do
is that we take the data out and we just
flatten it so that the spatial
dimensions of the pixels are flattened
so we keep the channel 1 channel 2
channel 3 syntax and then we pass that
to the function so if you have an RGB
image we basically just flatten it for
all the rows so so just have a flat 1d
list of pixels but still keep them RGB
RGB RGB and then if the function mean in
Mathematica gets that two-dimensional
array of RGB RGB RGB a gives one number
for minimum we also do the same thing
and don't treat it any differently we
give one number for the whole minimum
but if the function mean actually mattes
over those channels we as well map over
channels for image objects similarly for
audio objects I think this was one of
the difficult design discussions for us
to make sure that this you know now that
we have come to this conclusion it seems
trivial but I think anyways it's it's
very good convenient how you know to
remember how all of these work and how
do these relate to the original behavior
of the functions metadata support on the
development for images we have had them
for a while for audio we're gonna be
adding them another addition as I said
quickly demo this programmatic playback
we have an audio object we have added
this construct or wrapper called audio
stream which is basically a handle to
the audio object that we can start
playing and then it has properties like
how the channels are assigned whether we
should loop what's the device what's the
position and what's the status playing
paused or what and then this is for
instance the properties for that single
audio stream we can have multiple stream
attached to single audio object which
can be started to play at the different
times here
I play one pause half a second start
playing the other one and this is just a
simple example yeah I don't know what's
going wrong there
another one
okay so here we are basically creating
our own player where I can start playing
pauses we start playing and so for them
down here we'll see just a progress bar
so this is like a mini player put
together with the audio stream
capabilities better documented function
I'll just jump to one of the functions
mean shift filter we are making the
documentation cleaner but also a lot
more intuitive we are trying to insert
these illustrations maybe I should just
make that a little bit bigger quickly
we're adding descriptive text on top of
all of the functions explaining what
these function is supposed to do and
then having illustration and then the
filter cases we're doing 1 1 D 1 to D
for instance but also details about what
is the coordinate system this this
function works in and things like that
which is a lot easier than going through
the text and trying to visualize it in
your head and a lot of examples are
being added I just did a quick run we
now have a we now have over 350
functions overall for image audio and
signal processing over 4300 examples in
all of them so some of them like all
your plot has a lot of examples because
it's a plotting function it has a lot of
options and things like that on average
we have 12 and then some of them you
know have fewer if you have any question
this is the team of experts on image and
audio processing import/export of these
file formats look for all of us and
there are in fact a whole lot of other
talks that go more into depth and
details of all of these functionalities
that I try to very quickly highlight
Thanks
you